Joel McHale has no phone yes I also like
to talk about my mixed martial arts Joe
you're like a you're you're pretty you
you've become a very muscular man ba5
side you already out yes you've become
very buff are you a tough guy as well
now do you train or do you just like do
you just work out for aesthetics I'm an
old man and if I move too quickly one of
my joints will explode so I just I do it
I do a lot of running and I do a lot of
weightlifting yeah back being you know
old and I if I did jujitsu III I would
break very quickly
now do you did the White House
Correspondents Dinner in 2014 you were
very funny Michelle wolf to the last
year Trump didn't show up for it do you
think that that that kind of that event
is now not going to mean much anymore
just as the president's not there for
the next couple years
the president is not showing no matter
what your politics are the last how many
other presidents have participated I
think it shows real power and confidence
that you can take a joke and again
really it doesn't matter your part it
all play the president should be able to
take a joke and tell jokes and so I hope
he shows up next year but he won't
there's no way no he's gonna hold a
rally somewhere he just won't do it it's
gonna do his military parade that day no
they canceled that I remember talking to
reporters and from like Europe after
that and and I it was some guys from
Romania and I said if I did told these
jokes about your leader what would
happen to me and they heard they laughed
and said you'd be you'd be swinging a
hammer in a labor camp for the rest of
your life and I was like it just shows
you how cool America can be that you
could make fun of the most powerful
person on the planet and in the room
with him right in the room next to them
without it just shows incredible
confidence and
you know it I don't want to get all
preachy but really shows that we have
freedom and and so when the president
doesn't show for that again I'm not
being partisan it just showed I just
think it shows that there he might be a
little bit scared of the jokes and let
me ask you to you you are you're
Caroline's to one to seven five seven
forty one hundred tomorrow and Saturday
all I'm thinking today's Wednesday okay
so just for the weekend you're at
Caroline's on Broadway yes okay yes
you'll be there right I will be hours
and ask him to 25 show I mean I know
it's a good show wasn't about that is it
that it is it hard to do topical stuff
on that platform I think it's because
again I don't think they like my
sweaters but no I mean obviously Netflix
has trained their viewers to pin your
watch and we we actually tried that as
well but yeah I mean so far they have
not why I mean so far people you know
aren't watching Netflix that way I was
hoping you know ours would be the first
but you know they gave me 19 shots and
all you know I was very happy to do it
and because there they are the king of
the world right now so believe me I I
was very happy about the opportunity but
I would like to know if you guys have
any jobs for me what seems like you've
always got you're always working like
another thing you have Caroline's this
weekend you have a movie coming out you
know you're in the happy time murders
movie do you or do you kind of always
like to have something doable things
going yes I mean I'm a desperate
workaholic and I've always lived at like
when I was 14 I was washing dishes and
delivering newspapers and dealing
cocaine I just a lot of job and that's
how I could always look at that being in
our business it's always hustling so I
don't ever want to have to get a real
job so I'm all my wife is like can you
slow down
a little bit I'm like yeah just a second
and I'll be back in two days after I go
to boxing Mississippi to do yeah more
comedy so I've always I always am kind
of hustling to see what the next thing
is will end my life my life that's fine
you'll always work though because you've
already had shows that are proven
successful with the community and now
with the soup like you've been you've
had [ __ ] that worked for a long time so
if something doesn't go for as long as
you want you'll definitely get another
shot and I think it hurts people more if
this was their first shot and it didn't
work yeah and I'm just hoping that will
give me a job at some point since he's
king of the world right now he's doing
pretty well have you heard that song I
[Music]
have my kids are singing it now and my
ten and thirteen year old and I and yeah
they love it there I showed them the
video and I went now you know don't
shoot the clio but you does that blow
your mind how like kind of successful
he's been in now various different
avenues like it seems like a genre x'
genres if you will or did you not be I'm
now I'm gonna sound like one of those
guys but that you know it wasn't he is
he was always so talented and being
between takes a community he would sit
on this laptop and you could just be out
there kind of humming the beats and
saying the lot you you were like what
are you doing and he'd be like I'm just
putting together some songs and who
would have thought it
and and he so then you know when I saw
him ran for the first time in New York I
went oh my lord and thing and and so he
was always kind of on a different level
than the rest of us came in him and
Chevy Chase yeah I was gonna say Ken
Jong just because I like to put his name
out there and insult him you didn't have
a good week last week no but that crazy
rich Asians made so much money but Sonu
you one of those
really like Donald you I can I can
honestly say he's like the most talented
person I've ever worked with and I I
actively tried to stop him because I was
so jealous I don't blame you and but
that's one of those things worthy
because he's a good rapper it's a good
story but if he wasn't a good musician
that he used to write songs in between
takes would be something you talked
about cuz you hated them like and then
he would sit there and write songs it
would be like what the [ __ ] you doing
but because he's good at work that it's
a great artist well then on top of that
you got Atlanta where he wrote I mean
and his brain when ya then Deadpool he
was going to be he was writing that and
being executive producer of the cartoon
that FX was putting out and then they
said oh he's off then he then tweeted
out all the script pages and they were
hilarious so ok so it I don't know how
the guy has any time I mean I'm I still
go I'm I spent a lot of the time trying
to figure out what kind of yogurt I'm
gonna have in the morning it's it's he
think the man is a machine again I just
want to play call of duty for like an
hour a week and I can hardly find time
to do that so I don't know how he has
time to write him on top of that he's
Lando Calrissian so I don't all right
in hindsight him leaving community makes
sense cuz he left before the show was
over but when he when he left
were there any of you guys on the on the
staff or whatever in the cast going like
he's got to be [ __ ] crazy the show is
working like he's not really leaving for
anything in specific right I mean
obviously not hindsight being 20/20
you'd go like well yeah makes sense of
it was also after our fourth season sure
that he left when we didn't have Dan
Harmon and that season definitely
suffered for that obviously and so I
could will you add that all up he kind
of go it makes sense you know I wanted
to [ __ ] in that we did we did get Dan
back but I think at that point the
writing for him was already on the wall
and well you got what he's got and
you've got and you've got the vision
that he has you know you can I think
you're able to see a different
perspective
whereas I you know was like oh if I
do this many episodes then I can buy
this number of sweaters and a more
expensive dog well it works out because
it was donald glover but let's be honest
you know McLean Stevenson left mash that
didn't exactly pan out nicely so
sometimes decisions no he thought hello
Larry was really going to springboard so
is the silver lining to the Netflix show
being done that you don't have to watch
all the bad TV what while you're not
doing a soup type show do you get to
just ignore all the nonsense television
that you normally have to cover yes it's
a blessing and a curse because some of
those some of those shows are hard to
get through definitely I mean I god
bless Andy Cohen and the Empire he's
built but some of those Real Housewives
shows would make me want to pull my eyes
out because I go I wonder if they're
gonna get drunk and fight in this
episode oh it happened to get so yeah I
mean it's a bit though I some of the
stuff that we found from around the
world was really fun and like like what
does it love island that show that's
taking over all of Europe or the Jersey
Shore spin-offs
yeah like Warsaw is nowhere near the
shore so that that sort of stuff I kind
of took great Glee and but but so no now
I can go back to you know am I really
getting through all my Dostoevsky books
but yeah I would
I'm sure hopefully there'll be another
opportunity somewhere around to to make
fun of those again but who knows